okay a super chat from Bobby Polo hello
I am what you consider a hardcore trumpy
there are much more meaningful topics
that can be spoken about currently are
you open for debate so a couple
different things this particular stream
is about Trump apparently being about to
get arrested being very close to getting
arrested so that you can always say
there are other things to talk about
like when I talk about Healthcare it's
like why am I not talking about climate
change or when I talk about DeSantis why
am I not talking about Tim Scott or
whatever this stream is about the
forthcoming allegedly forthcoming arrest
of trump first of all am I open for
debate sure call in absolutely anytime
and
um you can ask me anything you want all
right here's Bobby Paul here's the guy
Bobby debate me sir go what do you want
to debate about
hello how are you I'm doing well
glad to hear
um I honestly didn't expect this I kind
of just hopped off and came back and I
saw this like whoa because you're the
one who said like I wouldn't debate
anyone and I wouldn't debate you and all
this stuff wouldn't you know strong word
it was a short statement but I do
appreciate you for taking me on Pleasure
um I'm not sure the spill over which
direction this will go so I'll just
start with like a blanket statement I
guess and I'll just get your opinion on
that okay so okay
so my question
so so and just for context you're a big
Trump supporter you said right
um
I mean in the grand scheme of things in
the moment with you know the way things
are going I would say
Trump is probably a better decision than
most people okay but you in the Super
Chat you said you're a hardcore trumpy
right that's what those were yours well
I did quotes because you know most
people I feel like just kind of
do a character battle and kind of just
demean the person instead of just kind
of attack the points I make so I was
just kind of just oh boy you know yeah
all right you use quotes fine all right
so let's let's hear it we're debating
now let's do it let's debate so my
question is so first off have you ever
seen the Doomsday Clock of the
scientific Doomsday Clock on where they
believe Society like how close
I have seen it it's not interesting to
me and I that's not interested I've
never looked at it in detail but I know
that we're all we're perpetually between
one and Five Minutes to Midnight or
something like that okay yeah so
obviously you would you would believe a
scientist's opinion on that that's
obviously going to hold some weight I
don't know so do would I believe a
scientist's opinion I tend to believe
the consensus of experts in the field in
which they are experts I don't know
enough about the Doomsday Clock to know
what scientists in What fields say what
about it you know okay well yeah I think
it's basically a metaphor I don't know
that that Doomsday Clock issues
originally it was actually created by
Einstein who obviously was part of
creating nukes and he obviously foresaw
the the future right that damn nukes are
around and this could take out all
society and he was the one who created
this okay so in foresight he created
this committee that groups basically all
the top experts in the world that get
together but this is a big debate as a
trump guy you want to talk about the
Doomsday Clock
um I mean you know in the moment I'm not
going to say I'm like totally prepared
because like you're everyone was making
it seem like I couldn't even talk to you
until Wednesday so I just hopped on
right now listen let me see if I can
talk you through some stuff hold on hold
on hold on please because I I I was like
because this is very important I feel
like because obviously yes I would like
to talk to Doomsday Clock is think about
if a nuke dropped on us right now
everything you're talking about is
completely absolutely
meaningless right about if everybody I
don't know that much about the Doomsday
club and I just don't know why it
matters I just don't get why I keep
talking over me I can't even finish a
statement you're losing the audience
with this topic Bobby who cares I'm
trying to have an articulate argument
it's like we can't even talk because you
keep just talking over me you care about
your audience or do you actually compare
it do you care about society and making
a meaningful change because this seems
like maybe just care to Pander to your
leftist audience instead of actually
talking about things that matter because
what I'm trying to do it
I didn't ask a question I'm still going
you just I'm trying to care about my
audience or do I care about Society yeah
because I'm trying to get to the point
though because it seems like you're just
trying to Pander to whatever people want
to hear but you're not actually trying
to get to the root cause because yes I
may be more on the right but I'm
actually an extremely moderate person
and logical and can come to a compromise
and that's the thing most people are
missing and I already can see that's not
what you're going to try to do here but
I would hope we could come to a
compromise but yes I will now give you
the floor I appreciate you for letting
me finish
um okay no so you had asked the question
do I care more about my audience or
society and I care about both and I
don't see either as being properly
served by you and I talking about the
Doomsday Clock that's all I was going to
say but I'll turn it back to you so you
can make your point or raise your
question remember you were eager to
debate me so we're I'm ready
so here's here's the point I'm trying to
make right okay so you right when so
Trump was running for president in
2016-2017 you as with your platform you
were making and I would say most media
99 of the left your impression was that
if Trump became president the world
would end the United States would
collapse essentially right a worst case
scenario if Trump became president right
I never said that so I okay
one request Bobby if you want to debate
me debate me about things I've said or
that I believe rather than things some
leftist somewhere said because that I
that's not a good that's not a good
thing you know that's fair can you
please then so just so I'm aware of with
context can you then tell me your
opinion on that matter just just a brief
summary my concern was that Trump would
debase and embarrass the United States
through his cartoonish nature I believe
that I was Vindicated on that in that
Global opinion of the United States and
of the American presidency was in the
toilet while Trump was President I also
believe that Trump would fail to
accomplish close to all of the things he
claimed he would accomplish and that's
also true and I believe that the things
Trump would do would mostly not be good
for the country and I believe I was
Vindicated there as well and we can look
at whether it's usmca or the Chinese
tariffs or how he handled covet so those
were the three things I believed ahead
of time and I would I would argue I was
Vindicated on all ahead of time oh well
hold on right because we're talking
about I asked for like the 2016-27
election the original 2017 election the
election was November 16. okay right I'm
just talking estimates the first time
Trump was President right your opinion
was was it oh my God this guy let don't
do not allow him by the any nuclear
device yes or no I I don't remember ever
saying first of all I the word
but it will allow him near a nuclear
device I don't remember saying that no I
mean certainly Bobby hold on a second
please you're asking me questions it was
a yes or no you know
I never said don't allow this guy near
any nuclear device I never said that you
believe that yes or no I was concerned
about Trump's lack of understanding of
the power of nuclear weapons okay as
demons Bobby please let me you're asking
questions and not letting me answer all
right I'm sorry I was concerned about
Trump having the type of access to nukes
that presidents have
because he demonstrated a lack of
understanding of the seriousness of
nuclear weapons
for example when he seemed not to
understand how crazy it would be to Nuke
Europe and when he asked about nuking
hurricane so for those reasons I was
concerned about Trump having access to
the Arsenal yes okay so just so I can
dumb it down for stupid people like me
you're just trying to say yes you were
trying to Advocate on your platform that
if Donald Trump got near these nuclear
devices the likelihood of the world
ending was significantly higher just due
to the fact of him being in that
position not even remotely what I'm
saying no Bobby you are I don't know and
I don't know if you're deliberately
misstating the things I'm saying or I
don't understanding them it feels like
you're filibustering because I must just
not be understanding then so can you
just explain it in a less filibustering
way and just in a more of a summary
because it didn't make sense then
because I don't I want to be polite here
I I just don't know if we're going to be
able to establish a mutual understanding
of you're not trying to you're trying to
kick me off and you're literally just
filibustering Bobby I've given you more
time than I ever give anyone that's
ridiculous you haven't given me enough
time we should have like an hour we
haven't gotten anywhere I mean you're
filibustering purposely and if your
whole audience should easily see that I
mean you're literally filibustering
we're not getting anywhere everybody
I'm Gonna Let You Go okay it's wondering
what filibustering is you won the debate
okay because you won the debate
everywhere
because you won you won buddy okay you
won you won Bobby one okay Bobby's gone
folks we can't do it right I mean it's
just like I don't think he could
understand
I know you Bobby won okay everybody
Bobby won wow people seem to have liked
that PC I just looked PC hippie Hendrix
I I am shocked that that drivel got
people to sign up uh Steve Ellis welcome
new member Lynn mazeka as well as James
Hoover and Jacob Angus you know it's
like I'm willing to entertain that stuff
every time but we go 20 minutes and he
he doesn't understand a single thing
that I'm saying
uh it's like how long do I have to do
that
how long do I have to do that before we
say I tried guys I tried